حده الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا تصاعدت في
ميدان المعركه وعلى مستوى الاعلام اذاعات
روسيه عده تعرضت لعمليه قرصنه وبثت خطابا
زائفا للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الخطاب تحدث عن غزو اوكراني واعلن فرض
الاحكام العرفيه في المناطق الحدوديه كما
دعى السكان المحليين الى اخلاء مناطقهم
الخطاب اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه المدججه
بالسلاح والمدعومه من واشنطن اجتاحت مناطق
كورسك وبالقرود وبريانسكا وتحدث ايضا عن
توقيع مرسوم رئاسي قريبا يفرض تعبئه
العامه في روسيا المتحدث باسم الكرملين
قال ان الرساله عباره عن عمليه قرصنه
مؤكدا ان الاذاعات المعنيه عاودت السيطره
على موجات بثها رساله بوتين المزيفه تاتي
بالتزامن مع اعلان يروج للهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد تم بثه في التلفزيون محلي بالقرم
المقطع اظهر جنودا اوكرانيين يضعون
اصابعهم على شفاههم في اشاره الى الهجوم
هي حرب تستعمل فيها كل الوسائل بما فيها
الاعلاميه خاصه من الجانب الاوكراني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات